nous pouvons bien sûr madame lavergne
est clair et votre lanterne et pas plus
et voici donc grâce à gérard pas bio et
son micro trottoir tout ce que vous avez
toujours voulu savoir sur le sexe n'est
ce pas mon cher woody sans jamais oser
le demander mineurs travaillent en
dessous et l'autre qui travaille aussi
dans quel domaine
le fait en général et le mineur de fond
il ya en dessous
qu'est ce que c'est que l'insémination
se former ses formes et des des curés
des jeunes purent et des pousses à la
halle au séminaire vous connaissez vous
l'insémination pourquoi je travaille et
les parties car et monsieur qu'est ce
que c'est une partie carrée ça peut être
une partie géométriques et à quatre
faces égale donc c'est une partie carrée
par exemple d'un élément on peut avoir
une partie karen partie rectangle une
partie triangulaire etes-vous monogame
monsieur non non je suis pom et bien
maintenant c'est là c'est la stéréo
maintenant c'était c'est dépassé sa
maison est-ce que c'est monogame basse à
ceux plus est dans ce système est-ce que
ça ira comme système
c'est un système de diffusion sur une
seule bande comment voyez-vous les
échanges de partenaires monsieur les
échanges de partenaires disons que ça
sur les sur le point de vue mondial
disons que allez on réussit quand ça va
bien pour le gaz peut-être n'en sais
rien maintenant est-ce que ça continuera
les pervers dont pensez vous je ne les
connais pas je connais les pères blancs
mais je connais pour les pervers alors
que seraient les pervers notoire des
périodes où du père bleus j'en sais rien
du tout mais en tout cas je ne connais
que les pères blancs une femme légère
je sais pas vous comptez 1 mais 70 si
vous mettez 10 kilos de moins êtes vous
pour le principe de la maison close
complètement non la maison bien isolée
mur toi fenêtres double vitrage moi je
les pose est chez moi on a gagné 25% de
on a fait une économie de 25 % de
chauffage êtes vous pour le ménage à
trois madame oui pourquoi pas parce
qu'elle dit que la femme rêve doit être
libre fabien pas tout le temps étant la
maison à faire le ménage
c'est normal que le mari est si tout le
monde travaille aujourd'hui que faut que
la femme et les chiens sa liberté comme
tout le monde tu connaissais vous comme
ce catalogue alors je connais déjà
donner de préférence des 3 suisses et
puis la redoute
l'homosexualité ça ne vous dit rien
absolument pas non non en tant que les
six voeux aux mots je comprends on s'en
sert pour la lessive enfin pour le
ménage quoi mais cette histoire de
l'homosexualité
j'avoue que tout autre en savon pourrait
très bien en place et l'exhibitionnisme
qu'est ce que c'est votre avis c'est les
juifs et sionistes sioniste veut dire
juif est alors l'exhibitionnisme qu'est
ce que ça serait le retour des juifs en
israël nymphomane où vous voyez ce que
ça signifie monsieur qu'est ce que c'est
l'information juifs et à la formation
alors parmi les nymphomanes qui
connaissait vos valeurs si tron morosi
et puis l'avoir d'arvor il informa gt
mais il jouait plus atteint mais c'est
pas parce qu'on est on n'est plus aux
journées info de 20h fournitures malice
mon cher gérard 21 micro trottoir
réalisé à nogent-le-rotrou au puy et à
béziers
notre lady